qui réagissent plus fortement c'est
peut-être parce qu'ils ont peur ils
connaissent pas bien ça valérie est la
maman de nathan 14 ans et de louis 11
ans à la maison la famille a fait le
choix de ne pas interdire l'usagé des
médias sociaux mais de contrôler les
périodes de temps alloué
on a préféré tabler sur nos règles à
nous son poste ferme
dur dur mais par exemple la table on
mange tout le temps tous les cinq à
table
puis on parle ensemble qui a aucun
appareil d'aucune sorte qu'ils rentrent
à table une étude de l'université
d'oxford publiée cette semaine est venue
déboulonner plusieurs mythes sur les
aspects néfastes des médias sociaux
l'étude conclut que les conséquences des
réseaux sociaux sur la satisfaction des
jeunes face à la vie minimes
les trois facteurs qui influencent
vraiment leur bonheur sont ancrés dans
la vie réelle soit le contexte familial
à la maison le cercle d'amis et la vie
scolaire
ce que je constate en bout de ligne
c'est que c'est leur mode de
communication de notre époque nous on
était après le téléphone mais ils sont
sur leur appareil dans cette étude qui
s'est échelonnée de 2009 à 2017
les chercheurs ont demandé à plus de 12
mille jeunes âgés de 10 à 15 ans le
temps qu'il passe est quotidiennement
sur les réseaux sociaux afin d'évaluer
leur indice de bonheur nathan affirme
que son compte instagram n'est pas au
centre de sa vie
je vois plus comme une source de
distraction genre pour se distraire
quand t'as rien à faire on dirait n'ai
vu un vrai plus il voit plus ça comme
quelque chose qui consomment de l'école
mais en vrai ce sont ces pour
communiquer avec nos amis
l'étude britannique est non seulement
l'une des plus étoffés jusqu'à ce jour
mais l'une des premières qui va à contre
courant car facebook est sorti
l'association des pédiatres
dès que ça allait causer la dépression
parce qu'ils voyaient que plus les gens
utilisaient facebook puis était déprimé
c'est une corrélation c'est pas une
cause à effet contrairement à leurs
parents
la vie des jeunes n'a pas été bouleversé
par la révolution numérique ce qui a été
démontré après c'est que les gens
déprimés ont tendance à utiliser plus
facebook donc avant de dire qu'un cause
l'autre il faut vraiment faire des
études comme celle qui a été fait et
quand c'est fait avec énormément de jeu
on veut que les jeunes s'adaptent très
bien je pense que c'est laid par action
plus très sec le cellulaire que les
jeunes dès la première année du
secondaire nathan a d'ailleurs eu un
cours sur l'utilisation des médias
sociaux
valérie a aussi choisi de miser sur la
prévention pour faire face à cette
réalité
on a appris à l'apprivoiser puis à vivre
avec finalement parce qu'on a pas choix
parce qu'on peut pas couper nos enfants
de leur monde de leur univers social
aussi elle se sent donc mieux outillés
pour le jour où son plus jeune louis lui
demandera son propre compte privé ici
pascal robidas radio canada ou en rien